Here with the incredibly talented, wonderful Adam Lambert.
(audience cheers)
Hi.
Thank you, Adam, so much.
Thank you.
You know, the fact that Queen,
one of the greatest bands to ever exist on the planet,
came to you and said, you know,
will you please step into Freddie Mercury's shoes?
Will you please bring our band back to life with us,
and go on tour now for many years?
What is it like to live in a Freddie Mercury world?
I mean, it helps that I have a lot of shoes of my own.
So I bring my own shoes to the party
figuratively and literally.
You know, I try really hard not to like mimic him
because out of respect, out of respect for the fans,
out of respect for the band.
I remember when I first started, I was very nervous.
I was so intimidated.
The idea of taking on the front man position in Queen
was like sacred ground.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I was just like, ooh, I don't know.
I don't know if the fans are gonna like be into this or not,
but I had to like, you know, tough it out and seem confident
as best of my acting ability could make me.
And yeah, the first couple of gigs were terrifying. (laughs)
I was like, ah! (chuckles)
I'm so glad that they picked you,
that they felt you were capable of, you know,
taking on such a legend.
And you guys have been doing it for years together.
And I know you're gonna be performing in Vegas
later this month.
Will you tell us about that?
Yeah, I mean, one of the things that I love is that,
yeah, I'm so fortunate
to be working with Queen all the time.
And then I get to have my solo career running parallel,
which is like a dream come true.
I'm very lucky, and that's what I'm doing in Vegas.
I'm doing solo shows at the Venetian.
These are songs of my own that I've written.
Songs that I've put out.
There's some good covers in there,
and being that it's the last two weekends of October,
which hosts my favorite holiday of all time,
I'm gonna, you know, I'm gonna give you
a little spooky, dark sided, you know, kind of journey.
So anybody that's coming, I'm really excited.
I'm putting together like, you know,
video content and my set list and I'm getting really pumped.
And also, I didn't mention just real quick,
if you can't come to Vegas for the show,
we are live streaming the show on the 29th.
So, check it out.
All the information is out there.
If you can't make it, check out the live stream.
Before we go, actually, Ruby,
you had a birthday recently?
I did last week.
Okay, and you have a final question for Adam?
I do. I do, Adam.
So no one officially is saying happy birthday to me,
and I was-
Ruby?
I know, can you believe that?
And I was wondering if you could sing happy birthday to me.
Absolutely.
Absolutely. Okay.
Thank you so much.
(Adam clears throat)
(audience laughs)
Okay.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday dear Ruby ♪
(audience cheers loudly)
Oh my God.
(audience cheering)
I have chills everywhere.
Oh by the way, Ruby,
we have a little birthday surprise for you actually.
You're gonna get a special invite
to Adam's live stream concert.
(audience applauds)
Oh my gosh.
Many people can go and enjoy actually,
and if you go to our website at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com,
we'll have all the details for you on there.
Adam Lambert, thank you so much for coming here today.
Thank you.
And it's just wonderful,
and I will be tuning in as well
as the many other things I mentioned on your CV.
I will be watching your beauty tutorials as well.
Thanks.
All right, well, tune into the premiere
of "Clash Of The Cover Bands" October 13th at 9:30 PM on E.
The best channel ever.
Plus, grab your tickets to see Adam perform in person
or on his livestream in Las Vegas later this month.
And be sure to check out his nonprofit as well,
The Feel Something Foundation, which is ever so important.
And will also be featured on our website
for any information.
So, thank you Adam so much.
Drew, thank you so much.
It's so nice talking to you.
It's so wonderful talking to you too.
(upbeat bright music)